Guys whether it’s pro play or Solo Q, powerful abilities are essential to any character’s
success.
Now, before we get into how we actually ranked this list of the Top 10 abilities.
Let's get a couple things straight, first of all no ultimates. We already did an entire video
Just for that.
Second of all, no items and no passives either.
Oh and if you want the ABILITY to swag out your wardrobe.
"How do you do fellow kids."
...well check out theScore esports online Merch Department where we got some pretty sick t-shirts
like this one.
Now I'm done selling out, let's get on with the list.
From the strongest, to the meta defining to the iconic, here are the Top 10 Abilities
Kicking off our list is Invoker’s Sun Strike from Dota 2. Sure, we could have put his Invoke ability on this list,
but that felt like cheating, so we decided to highlight his global nuke.
(Casting)
Sun Strike is a straightforward, flashy and powerful skill shot
that is responsible for some of Dota’s hypest kills.
(Casting)
It can be aimed anywhere on the map with or without vision, and serves as a constant threat for retreating
enemies.
Due to the short cast time before it lands, sun strike it one of the harder skill shots to hit in Dota,
but when it does, it brings the crowd to their feet.
(Casting)
We bet you were expecting Pudge, Roadhog or Blitzcrank here,
but with so many grab and pull abilities it was hard to just pick one.
With that said, Thresh’s hook has a unique property that sets it apart,
which is why it comes in at number 9 on our list.
(Casting)
With the option to travel to the hooked target,
Thresh has the most versatile hook ability in League of Legends
(Casting)
In terms of League of Legends it’s got a pretty long range,
short cast time and serves as a long enough disable to basically guarantee death
when combined with the rest of Thresh’s kit.
(Casting)
I guess that’s why it’s called a Death Sentence.
Number 8 on our list goes to the skill that everyone loves to hate.
That’s right, it’s Yasuo’s wind wall.
With the ability to negate all projectiles including certain ultimates,
Wind Wall makes Yasuo one of the most flexible melee characters in League of Legends
(Casting)
It allows him to bully ranged carries in lane and single handedly disrupt team fights
thanks to the width and nearly instantaneous cast time.
(Casting)
Coming in at our number 7 spot is Nature’s Prophet’s Teleportation which is,
well, exactly what it sounds like.
It allows the user to teleport anywhere on the map without requiring vision,
and what you choose to do with such power is entirely up to you.
(Casting)
Teleportation gives Nature’s Prophet a global presence throughout the game,
making him one of the scariest heroes to play against as just his existence alone
applies pressure to the entire map.
(Casting)
Oh, and don’t even think about leaving your own base.
In League of Legends, Tahm Kench is one of the hardest Champions to kill
and is able to survive in situations almost no other Champions could.
And thanks to Devour, he can lend that survivability to an ally
putting it at number 6 on our list.
(Casting)
Not only can Devour save allies from certain death,
But Tahm Kench can use it offensively as well to swallow an enemy
rendering them useless in a fight
only to be spat back out into the clutches of his team.
(Casting)
Simply put, A good Tahm Kench can change the entire flow of the game
with expert use of Devour.
(Casting)
Living Shadow is one of the most iconic non ultimate abilities in all of League of Legends
which is one of the reasons it lands in at number five on our list.
(Casting)
Zed’s W skill allows him to safely harass in lane thanks to the shadow mimicking
his other abilities,
and with the added option to swap places with his shadow,
it offers all the traditional utility of a Flash.
(Casting)
Combined with the rest of Zed’s arsenal, Living Shadow enables him to dive a target
while staying deceptively safe, unlocking much of Zed’s terrifying outplay potential.
(Casting)
Coming in at number 4 is the fireball that redefined the entire fighting game genre.
The Hadouken was the first projectile to appear in a fighting game,
and marked the first time in which a character could control space away from their body.
(Casting)
Every Street Fighter game is balanced around the fireball,
allowing for styles of play that otherwise wouldn’t exist.
The Hadouken inspired ranged abilities in other fighting games and has become a staple of the genre.
(Casting)
And perhaps the only thing more iconic in Street Fighter than Ryu himself, is his Hadouken.
Previously seen in the form of an ultimate and now turned into a basic ability,
our number 3 spot goes to Mercy’s Resurrect.
While its modern day form is not quite as powerful as it’s original rendition,
reviving a single ally is more than enough to change the course of a fight.
(Casting)
As a basic ability, Mercy’s resurrect is now far more impactful throughout the game
than its previous iteration which required an ultimate charge.
And despite having the longest cooldown of any basic ability in the game,
it is often more than enough to win a battle.
(Casting)
Fissure may have been the most impactful basic ability of the past two Internationals
and perhaps throughout the history of Dota 2,
which is why it’s the runner up on our list.
(Casting)
It has an AoE stun, persists after being casted to block movement and can be thrown out from a safe distance.
Hitting a Fissure can set up other harder to hit skills and basically spells death
for any unsuspecting foe.
More often than not you won’t see it coming, and even if you do it’s not easy to dodge.
(Casting)
In the hands of a skilled player, Fissure is one of the strongest initiation tools in all of Dota 2.
Taking the crown is the most important ability in any MOBA: blink,
a skill that lets you instantly teleport a short distance.
While simple in nature, the versatility that it offers is undeniable and single handedly changes the way
a game can be played,
enabling high mechanic offensive and defensive plays.
(Casting)
And it’s not just limited MOBAs, characters like Dhalsim from Street Fighter
and Tracer from Overwatch also share the mechanic.
The most iconic iteration belongs to Anti-Mage and Queen of Pain,
who can access blink from level 1 without purchasing an item,
giving them pressure and safety in the early phases of the game.
(Casting)
And blink never falls off, as it can be used to accelerate farm, finish off enemies,
and escape from danger all throughout the match.
Outside of Dota, blink is one of the most important mechanics in any competitive video game
and is the most powerful basic ability there is.
Plain and simple.
(Casting)
Well guys that’s all we got on Top 10 this week.
Now why are you still watching, go buy a shirt or something.